gotta be honest with you those bad boys
movies bad boys wanted to I enjoy them
call it guilty pleasure call it whatever
you want but it's like if you take
Michael Bay that alien robot who came to
earth to make movies and you take his
Michael Bay ISM essence you inject it
into a buddy cop movie you have Will
Smith and Martin Lawrence lending their
charisma and chemistry on-screen just
makes for something I can watch and
enjoy now there's a third one I don't
think they would have yet here we are as
review
[Music]
bad boys for life which is funny because
you would think they'd save that title
for the fourth one bad boys for maybe
they shouldn't have stand it out loud
sounded dumber okay so bad boys for life
is the third bad boys movies not
directed by Michael Bay this time but we
have Will Smith and Martin Lawrence
return and you have a baddie out there
executing seemingly random people so
like alright who are these people why is
this bad person executing them let's get
to the bottom of it and I got to say
Will Smith and Martin Lawrence there's
good together they've always been great
together in the bad boys movies and
they're still great together I want to
give special love to Martin Lawrence cuz
you always hear about Will Smith he's
the superstar but apparently Martin
Lawrence was retired and came out of
retirement for this movie which makes me
go oh does he still have it I'm kind of
nervous but I mean he does still have it
the dude is great his comedic timing is
on points like he never left so that
dynamics still in here little tweaks
here and there with Will Smith but I'll
get to that later some enjoyable action
sequences in this movie nothing quite as
good as the freeway scene in bad boys 2
because it's pretty legendary
it's pretty good I've always enjoyed the
car onslaught that is the bad boys 2
freeway chasing I didn't really enjoy
any chase sequence in this movie as much
as that saying there's still some
enjoyable action sequences less
shaky-cam than when Michael Bay did it
I'll say that with the action sequences
in this movie the cameras on the target
for a little longer or on two people
fighting for a little longer than before
makes things feel a little more coherent
however I can't believe it is that loud
oh god it is missing a little bit of
that high-octane energy that Michael Bay
does bring to it but but I feel like
that's a conscious decision and those
are those tweaks I mentioned earlier but
I said I would talk about them later I
guess it's later I do feel like with
this movie bad boys has run into what a
lot of 80s and 90s action movie
franchises have run into which is at
what point does the lead or leads at
what point do they out age themselves
sadboys was about a couple of young
hothead cops one more of a hothead than
the other one because Mike Lowrey is
clearly the hotter shoot first ask
questions later that's a quality that
you can roll with if they're 20
something-year-old bad boys to
30-something euros but they still made
it work now they're 50 and you can't
really do that with them any more comes
across as irresponsible is like you guys
are supposed to have learned
in the decades since this thing started
so want to get in the props of the fact
that they had the characters age he feel
like there is a bit of a change in tone
which is a byproduct of age but they do
make it work it still feels like a bad
boy sequel this is bad boys 3 it's just
been 25 years since the whole thing
started so now we're here it's not like
Indiana Jones is all like urine a
teacher hard time no that should be
full-time that should be your full-time
job teaching cuz you're gonna be out
there in the ruins of nothing's Ville
you're gonna break your hip and no one's
gonna know where you are and you're
gonna die it's very irresponsible don't
do that it was actually really amazed if
not impressed if they had the characters
aged but didn't make them feel like
characters other than themselves little
older now a little wiser a little less
hot-headed but they still have
hot-headed moments because people am i
right crazy animals those people but it
makes me really interesting going
forward I hear they want to do a bad
boys floor I can see them going another
direction whereas bad boys 1 & 2 it's
like alright these hot-headed young cops
going forward I can see them making it
something different something a little
more concrete and seasons which crazier
things have happened The Fast and the
Furious used to be hip out a bunch of
knuckleheads racing for slips now
they're heist movies it can happen and
the movie had a memorable villain I feel
it's important in a movie like that it's
a gold standard for forgettable as a
villain is probably a good day to die
hard
I don't remember jack [ __ ] about the
villain in there I think there are
multiple villains are they Russians I
think point is I like a villain I can
remember and the villain in here as well
as the dynamic it's a memorable thing so
in the end bad boys for life I actually
enjoyed it I feel like it's lost some of
the energy from the first bad boys
movies I don't know if it's because
Michael Bay is not there to inject it or
he's not there to inject it because well
the characters have aged past it oh and
all bad boys for life it's pretty fun a
pretty fun time no alcohol required
alright so bad boys for life have you
seen it what do you think about it how
does it compare to the first two bad
boys movies whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]